[Música]
en France 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy Valentina
Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos en esta ocasión iniciamos
en Escocia porque científicos del Centro
Nacional de océanografía realizaron un
experimento con alta tecnología para
determinar si es viable almacenar
emisiones de carbono bajo el mar y
reducir estos gases contaminantes en la
atmósfera puntualmente fueron sumergidos
cilindros grandes llenos de dióxido de
carbono y el gas fue inyectado en un
depósito a tres metros bajo el suelo
marítimo y luego un conjunto de robots y
sensores algunos operados por un
vehículo submarino probaron cuánto de
ese carbono almacenado se filtró al mar
básicamente lo hicimos durante un
periodo de 11 días liberamos 640
kilogramos de CO2 que no es mucho es
menos que el CO2 que se obtiene cuando
un avión despega de la pista pero Fue
suficiente para nosotros para hacer lo
que necesitábamos hacer el gas estaba en
cilindros y pasamos una manguera desde
los cilindros hasta básicamente la
tubería que habíamos puesto debajo de
los sedimentos y luego empezamos a
liberar el gas pudimos controlar muy
sensiblemente la tasa de liberación
entonces durante el periodo del
experimento aumentamos desde una masa
muy muy baja hasta algo que pensamos que
sería lo que la gente estaría buscando
Esta no es una técnica nueva los
responsables del proyecto explican que
es un método que sea estudiado Durante
los últimos 30 años no obstante el
objetivo particular de este estudio es
determinar si son capaces de detectar
cualquier tipo de fuga por pequeña que
sea Asimismo recolectar toda la
información suficiente que requerirían
las autoridades reguladoras para
determinar que la técnica Es segura en
caso de que se implemente a gran escala
[Música]
la audiencia inicial o la evidencia
existente es que siempre que los sitios
de almacenamiento estén bien regulados y
monitoreados esperaríamos mantener el
98% del carbono en de almacenamiento
durante 10.000 años o más así que
estaríamos observando tasas anuales de
fuga muy muy bajas
nuestra garantizado que haya habido un
monitoreo realmente bueno y se ha
calculado que en algunos de los peores
escenarios en lugar de mantener el 98%
del carbono bajo tierra se podría estar
más cerca del 80% o menos
Entonces lo que realmente debemos
asegurarnos es que continuamos
monitoreando las fugas en cualquier
sitio de almacenamiento
los expertos explican que el
almacenamiento bajo el suelo marítimo de
CO2 es una solución temporal para
mitigar los efectos del gas carbónico en
la atmósfera hasta llegar a un punto de
cero emisiones que realmente es la única
solución a largo plazo
vamos ahora al espacio porque la agencia
espacial china logró acoplar con éxito
el primer módulo laboratorio a su
estación tiangong se trata del buen tian
el primer segmento que se une al módulo
central tiange el proceso de
acoplamiento duró unas 13 horas el tiene
una longitud de 17,9 metros y al igual
que el tiange está equipado con
instalaciones de vivienda para los
astronautas incluidas tres áreas para
dormir un baño y una cocina cuenta con
una cabina de esclusa de aire que se
convertirá en el principal punto de
entrada y salida para las actividades
extravehiculares una vez activas
reemplazando el papel que ahora
desempeña el centro de atraque de tianji
no obstante su principal objetivo es
albergar experimentos científicos al
mismo tiempo que proporcionar copias de
seguridad para las funciones de control
y soporte vital del tiange
volvemos a la Tierra y nos desplazamos a
Londres Donde fueron desarrolladas unas
gafas equipadas con Inteligencia
artificial llamadas x-ray el dispositivo
permite a quienes las usan visualizar
subtítulos en tiempo real mientras
conversan algo sumamente favorable para
personas con discapacidad auditiva
parcial o total las gafas cuentan con
realidad aumentada y se conectan con
teléfonos inteligentes mediante una
aplicación que recoge cualquier sonido y
lo convierte en texto que se muestra en
el interior de los lentes
tomamos ese flujo de audio del micrófono
a las gafas lo estamos ejecutando a
través de un software de transcripción
que los usuarios probablemente hayan
visto antes la capacidad de convertir el
audio en subtítulos sin embargo lo que
estamos haciendo es tomar esos
subtítulos y ponerlos en realidad
aumentada si alguno de ustedes tiene una
pantalla de advertencia dentro de su
automóvil es exactamente la misma
tecnología que usamos esas imágenes se
proyectan directamente en tus ojos el
software Aún se está desarrollando pero
ya puede reconocer quién está hablando y
pronto tendrá el poder de Traducir
idiomas tonos de voz y acentos por ahora
los responsables prueban una versión con
personas que no pueden leer los labios o
tienen dificultad para captar varias
conversaciones que ocurren a la vez para
ayudar a desarrollar el programa de una
forma más avanzada
y finalizamos en el distrito de shibuya
en Tokio donde un perro gigante
proyectado en 3DS está llevando las
miradas de miles de transeúntes mientras
salta a través de vallas publicitarias
para atrapar un frisby se trata de una
quita que aparece una vez cada hora a
través de ocho pantallas separadas el
perro gigante 3D toca una campana luego
salta un elevador que lo sube a lo más
alto de un edificio dicha construcción
tiene un reloj de manecillas por allí se
asoma para después atrapar el frisbee
previamente los responsables de este
proyecto crearon un gato en 3D en el
distrito de shinjuku que se volvió viral
pero shibuya es famoso por la célebre
historia de Hachiko una quita recordado
por la lealtad a su amo quien falleció
en una clase de la Universidad de Tokio
el perro tenía como costumbre de
encontrarse con él en la estación de
shibuya y se sentó a esperarlo fuera
durante 10 años así concluimos este
espacio a ustedes gracias por su
sintonía continúen con toda nuestra
programación en France 24 y France
24.com
[Música]